it's easy to forget that the U.S still
has colonies
but we don't actually use the word
colony we prefer words like
unincorporated territory or Commonwealth
these are places where people are
subject to U.S rule but don't enjoy the
full rights that other Americans do I
want to tell you about one of them
Puerto Rico
when you're in Puerto Rico you're not
just in a vacation Paradise you are in a
part of the United States it feels like
the United States but it also feels
distinctly different this feeling this
limbo State didn't happen by accident in
fact it's perhaps the best example of
the lengths the United States has gone
to hold on to land
so let me show you how the US kept their
colony in the Caribbean using Brute
Force spying and the abuse of land and
people
this is how the U.S stole Puerto Rico
[Music]
pause the video really quick
um I need to just tell you something
which is that about three years ago I
started seeing a therapist because I was
kind of not in a happy place in my life
and needed to talk to somebody and it
kind of changed my life it really
changed my life I'm telling you this
because it has to do with who's
sponsoring today's video thank you
better help for sponsoring today's video
and the channel generally I didn't grow
up going to therapy or really understood
I sort of thought it was only four if
like I had some big mental illness and I
needed help I go see a therapist what
I've learned is that therapy is actually
something that I think we all need and
the same way that we all need exercise
for our physical bodies we need help
with our mental selves as well and that
is what therapy can do and better help
is a platform that makes it really easy
to find a good therapist and start
communicating with them immediately with
better help you sign up you take a quick
quiz and then they match you with a
licensed therapist in their giant
network of tens of thousands of their
therapists that are all over the place
that's not limited to your geographic
location once you're connected to a
therapist you can very quickly start
communicating however you want you can
do text message sessions you can do
video call you can do phone call finding
a therapist the traditional way I've
found is a much more difficult and
arduous process which when you're
looking for a therapist you don't want
any friction it's not a very fun thing
to do with better help if your therapist
isn't a good fit you can switch to a new
one for free in the end betterhelp is
trying to make therapy more accessible
to all of us so that we can learn more
about our minds our minds and our
emotions work and hopefully live better
lives there's a link in my description
it's betterhelp.com Johnny Harris you
get a 10 off your first month of better
help so you can try it out at a discount
and see if it fits into your life
there's also financial aid for those who
need it so thank you better help for
existing and sponsoring today's video
and now let's dive back into Puerto Rico
okay so it's 18.98 and the Spanish
Empire looks like this
but it's faltering a lot of its colonies
are fighting for Independence the United
States gets involved and allies with a
lot of these Independence Fighters they
say they want to liberate these colonies
and so they get into the war and they
win but instead of liberating Spain's
colonies they just take them for
themselves and one of those colonies was
Puerto Rico
and so on an ordinary Tuesday in the
late 1800s there was a quiet ceremony
that takes place on the governor's
balcony in San Juan after 400 years of
Spanish rule Puerto Rico this island in
the Caribbean is simply passed from one
ruler to the next and this begins an
unprecedented experiment in the
Caribbean for the United States an
operation to extract resources money
labor and Military protection from this
small beautiful island they start by
passing a law that gives the U.S total
political control over the island they
start appointing American leaders to
govern the island men who don't speak
Spanish don't know anything about Puerto
Rico or its people most of these leaders
treat the assignment like a business
venture
like this one guy who when he was the
leader of Puerto Rico starts to give
public Puerto Rican funds to
American-owned businesses on the island
then he Stacks the government with
American loyalists and then eventually
he resigns but then he returns to the
island to build a sugar Kingdom now with
the help of all of the political
officials that he had appointed this
company balloons into the largest global
sugar business on Earth and when it's
Domino you're sure it's pure at the same
time U.S banks descend on the island
giving out very predatory loans and then
foreclosing on land gobbling it up and
turning it into you guessed it sugar
Farms Puerto Rico is slowly turning into
a sugar Island and becoming more and
more dependent on shipments from the
mainland the U.S enacts a new policy
that says that anything going into
Puerto Rico has to be transported by
American ships with American Crews so of
course the skyrockets the prices for
locals which is made worse by the fact
that the US government had devalued and
then outlawed the local currency so now
every Puerto Rican lost almost half of
their wealth overnight and as a part of
this push to lock Puerto Rico in as
their colony they forbid Spanish in
schools and public institutions and so
in this very short amount of time the
U.S turned Spain's former Colony into
this giant sugar farm stripping down
local identity and language and culture
in the process and locking the people
under their control and then Congress
gives Puerto Ricans U.S citizenship
which conveniently was just in time for
a giant global war so Puerto Rican men
got sent to the front lines to fight for
the country that was in the process of
pillaging their Island by 1922 a series
of Supreme Court cases had solidified
Puerto Rico as a quote unincorporated
territory which is just like word salad
for the U.S Constitution doesn't fully
apply here I mean think about it
unincorporated territory this
intentionally contradictory jargon that
came from these men hundreds of miles
away but honestly the message was very
clear Puerto Ricans did not look or
sound enough like Americans to actually
be a part of the United States
foreign
by the 1930s big Banks owned 60 percent
of these sugar Farms eighty percent of
the tobacco farms and a hundred percent
of the railroads and shipping facilities
at the same time Puerto Ricans were
being paid less than four cents an hour
if you put that into today's currency by
inflation that's like a dollar an hour
poverty and malnutrition start to grip
this island all the while the US is
turning the island into an essential
military Outpost see how Puerto Rico
juts out a little bit into the Caribbean
it served as a strategically positioned
Island to help protect trade routes and
a place where you could refuel ships
over time more and more military bases
and installations start to pop up on
this island the US would go on to test
thousands of bombs in Puerto Rico
leaving behind one of the most hazardous
waste sites in the United States and by
the middle of the 1900s Puerto Rico
really starts to mirror what the U.S
envisioned Puerto Rico the sugar
Metropolis
Puerto Rico the land of low wages and
abundant laborers
Puerto Rico the Irreplaceable military
Outlaws
the Empire that built themselves as the
liberators from Spain is now an Overlord
and the locals start fighting back
[Music]
the fight is led by this guy Pedro
albisu Campos he's this poor kid who
ends up going to Harvard he graduates
valedictorian from Harvard Law School he
serves the U.S in World War one and even
helps draft Ireland's Independence
Constitution like the guy's kind of a
superstar ultimately he returns to his
hometown to attempt The Impossible
Puerto Rican Independence but soon
Campos would find himself bouncing in
and out of prison for 25 years
things haven't quite escalated this
movement is just starting Campos comes
back to Puerto Rico with the goal of
total separation from the United States
and people join him a lot of people just
everyday ordinary Puerto Ricans who are
fed up with being exploited they join
them they organize and they call
themselves The nationalists they run for
office they go on strike and they fight
back against this superpower that has
been exploiting them momentum begins to
pick up
and then the dominoes really start to
fall there was this American doctor his
name is Cornelius Rhodes and he went to
Puerto Rico sane is going to do like
health research or something we know
what he really was doing and thinking
because he wrote this letter let me read
it to you he writes that Puerto Ricans
are quote Beyond doubt the dirtiest
laziest and most degenerate and thievish
race of men ever to have inhabited this
sphere and he goes on to say that it
makes him sick to quote inhabit the same
island with them but it doesn't stop
there he says that Puerto Ricans need
quote something to totally exterminate
the entire population and then he admits
to a crime he says I have done my best
to further the process of their
extermination by killing off eight and
transplanting cancer into several more
I mean this is bad this is it's really
bad but for a lot of Puerto Ricans
this wasn't surprising so the staff at
the hospital find this letter and they
send it around to everyone and it goes
out and it goes viral and nothing
happens to this guy who has admitted to
murdering a bunch of Puerto Ricans
actually something does happen he gets
uh on the front cover of Time Magazine
to the nationalists this letter confirms
something that they already knew it
actually wasn't that surprising there
was an awareness that yes America loves
Puerto Rico for their soil and their
labor and their strategic location but
hates them as people so after this
letter the movement explodes
[Music]
it gets to the point where the US and
their puppet government on the island
can no longer ignore this movement soon
a bunch of new officers are hired and
trained and armed with machine guns and
tear gas but the nationalists keep
fighting then in 1935 police kill four
nationalists at a university event the
nationalists retaliate by killing the
police chief then without trial the
police execute his killer and arrests
Campos the leader of the movement for
plotting to overthrow the government
Campos has given this rigged trial with
a jury made up mostly of Mainland
Americans and he gets sentenced to
prison for 10 years a few months later
people are out peacefully protesting on
Palm Sunday and the police start
shooting into the crowd men women
children and Elders are all clubbed and
beaten to death and shot in the back as
they run away 19 are killed and over 100
are wounded but it still doesn't put
down the movement the violence only
pours fuel on the Fire
back in Washington DC they're starting
to get worried that this Independence
Movement is just going to keep building
and they don't want to give up their
island in the Caribbean there's still
plenty of money to be made off of Puerto
Rican soil and labor not to mention the
military bases that they had there so
they turned to an extreme measure
something that as I learned about as we
reported on has been blowing my mind in
a way that I you know I study this stuff
a lot I look at the behavior of Empires
and look at how they control people I've
never seen this before
starts with FBI agents who come to the
island to work with the police of Puerto
Rico they have one simple mission to spy
on anyone who they deem politically
subversive and to sabotage them and thus
sabotage the independence movement so
they spy on everyone they spy on the
nationalists who are part of the
movement but also their friends their
Partners their sexual partners their
business colleagues their children they
track down criminal records and
Mistresses and debtors and creditors and
photos and license plate numbers school
transcripts and even the guest list to
weddings like they got really really
detailed they started listening in on
phone calls and intercepting letters
everything was fair game the idea was to
create panopticon this idea that they're
always watching they also started to
cultivate relationships with a network
of informers often the victim's family
or friends or neighbors would get sucked
into this state spying apparatus the FBI
uses payments and coercion and
manipulation which often forces people
to turn turn on each other causing
divorce and broken friendship and
fractured communities much of this was
done undercover like these FBI agents
would just be dressed in normal clothes
but would be constantly surveilling the
people around them oh and we know about
this because they documented everything
[Music]
foreign
if you are a person of interest you
probably had a file all of these files
they're called the carpetas our story
producer Rafaela went to San Juan to see
the carpetas first hand so I'm at the
general Archive Building in San Juan in
Puerto Rico to see these secret
surveillance documents that were
collected on thousands of Puerto Ricans
over so many decades after weeks of work
I finally got to look at lascaripidus to
see what was actually in these files and
it's kind of creepy I have to say you
see specific times and dates and details
for meetups detailed descriptions of the
locations where people are just meeting
all of the names of people involved
these subgroups that were potentially
supporters of the independence movement
you get these highly detailed physical
descriptions of the people that they
were tracking their occupation the model
of their car their license plate number
and all of their moves all of their
activities what they were doing who they
were supporting and even for those who
moved away from Puerto Rico they
continued to track them knowing exactly
what apartment they lived in in the
Bronx they speculated about their
nationalistic Tendencies and then you
see these interviews that agents were
having with people close to the Target
where their personal beliefs are
revealed like one who thought that
Puerto Rico would be repaired with
socialism and Independence you can see a
source telling these agents that they're
afraid that their friend had become
friends with the leaders of the
independence movement and had been
inducted it in because of this
friendship and of course these
informants request that all this
information they're spilling to the
agents quote be kept secret these agents
would even interview family members like
there's this whole transcript of the
agents talking to the mother of someone
who was suspected to be a part of the
independence movement oh yeah and in all
of these documents you see an obsession
with who had guns it's hard to overstate
how exhaustive this spying effort was
and how powerful it was the FBI was able
to use all this information to
intimidate and blackmail and punish
suspected nationalists I mean there are
thousands of these examples from
children being like kidnapped and put
into a helicopter by the FBI to people
being denied government jobs all because
they had a carpeta at the end of the day
it was psychological war against Puerto
Ricans who wanted Independence and it
worked horrifically well in dividing
these people and making them feel
powerless because they were always being
watched in their most personal of
moments
oh and it wasn't just a couple of years
this lasted for decades eventually it
gets to the point where Campos and the
nationalists see no other way other than
armed revolution in the fall of 1950 the
nationalists declare Puerto Rico as an
independent nation they attempt to seize
towns to set government buildings on
fire to cut phone lines they try to
assassinate the governor and let's be
honest it's 1950 like the United States
is easily the most powerful country to
have ever existed these people had no
chance of winning against the newly
crowned Global superpower their goal was
to bring attention to the world to
pressure the U.S to give up its Colony
but instead the United States responded
by dropping bombs the only time in the
history of the United States where they
bombed their own citizens One Survivor
of the Revolution was interviewed five
years ago and said that it was a David
against Goliath situation and that their
leader told them that they might die but
that they might succeed but that at
least it would have let the world know
about Puerto Rico during this revolution
many of the fighters wore their Sunday
Best ironed suits and pressed ties
because they knew they would die they
had a cause they were fighting for in
the end two dozen are killed Puerto Rico
really didn't have a chance President
Truman comes out and is sort of like
there was an incident in Puerto Rico
sort of downplays it and a couple days
later two nationalists attempt to
assassinate him the world doesn't come
to Puerto Rico's rescue and instead the
police carry out a mass arrest throwing
three thousand people in jail a few
years later four nationalists opened
fire in the chamber of the U.S Congress
Campos is arrested again and this time
he's sentenced to 80 years in prison
there's evidence that during this time
in prison Campos was exposed extreme
levels of radiation the consequences
allegedly gave him a stroke and left him
paralyzed and unable to speak in the end
the US's wish came true they silenced
Campos for good
after the squashing of the Revolution
the surveillance program continued for
decades in the end it was a total of 50
years of state-sanctioned spying on the
people of Puerto Rico when it all came
to light they estimated that around a
hundred thousand people had files a lot
of people in Puerto Rico knew that this
was happening but they just knew it in
their gut they didn't have any real
evidence of it they didn't realize the
sheer scale the methodical approach that
the FBI was taking to spy on them and to
divide them into psychologically debase
them in total it was 1.8 million pages
of documentation and many of the victims
of this spine are still alive today I
think the carpetas are a really powerful
signal of how the U.S kept its colony in
the Caribbean they were the cementing of
what the U.S had done from the beginning
which is create a system of Reliance and
oppression where people lived and died
under the thumb of this massive
superpower that was exerting very very
aggressive control over these people
these people who were American citizens
it's hard to fully understand and
impossible to relate to the
psychological impact that this program
would have on the people that it
affected but also the generations who
came from the people who had affected
imagine such a pervasive force that was
sowing division mistrust betrayal and
fear not just of the government but of
each other Puerto Rico never got
independence and to this day they remain
an unincorporated territory which means
that they don't have the same rights as
other American citizens and the status
of the island is a heated debate many
Puerto Ricans value the modern day
benefits of being connected to the U.S
but at what cost
this is backlit by the US's lasting
control over the island and even though
the people of Puerto Rico served in our
Armed Forces they still can't vote for
the president they still don't have full
representation in our democracy and yet
Puerto Rico still has this immense
impact on American culture and life the
food the music the dance the art from
this island it's a part of what it means
to be American and yet I think most of
us don't really think about the status
of this place very often or its history
it's only when there's like a hurricane
on this island and we see the U.S kind
of barely show up relative to how they
show up for their other citizens only
then are we reminded that Puerto Rico is
a colonial possession one taken in war
and exploited through predatory and
racist policies and then held on to
through a massive amount of State Force
spying violence and repression and what
we're left with is yet another example
of a place whose vibrant spirit and
culture and people are somehow able to
shine through the dark fog of colonial
abuse that has left deep wounds on this
island
foreign
[Music]